hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the key central claims of david
hume's philosophy considered as a whole
takes place in the inquiry concerning
human understanding
specifically in section 5 which is
entitled skeptical solution of these
doubts the doubts are those raised
earlier in section 4 and David Hume is
often talked about as being a sceptical
philosopher but he's the kind of skeptic
that thinks that you know we don't have
an overall way of approaching things in
the world or even in the life of the
mind as skeptics who demand evidence for
every single thing and say well we can't
really know anything he's not a dogmatic
skeptic he's a skeptic who thinks that
skepticism itself will reveal to us at
least some ways of getting by and this
applies in particular to what we can
call practical philosophy dealing with
action dealing with the world dealing
with what we're deciding to do or not to
do our prioritizations are choices right
but it also deals with what he calls
speculative philosophy as well and he's
delving in that section into how does
cause-and-effect really work if it's not
based on any sort of experience of the
causal connection between what we think
to be cause-and-effect why is it that we
buy into it and if we don't have an
answer for this then it seems like all
of our reasonings concerning what he
calls matters of fact or real existence
the relation between empirical things in
the world like a chalkboard and my
knuckle and the sound that it makes and
the solidity that it has all of those
seem to become questionable they get
called into doubt and him says as a
matter of fact that's not what happens
with us we we don't doubt about all
these things so it's kind of weird
what's actually going on there and he's
asking us well what principle allows us
to
reason beyond the experiences that were
having he tells us that we don't have to
fear that that philosophy will endeavors
to limit our inquiries to common life
well ever undermine the reasonings of
common life and carry its doubts so far
as to destroy all action as well as
speculation nature will always maintain
her rights and prevail on the end over
any abstract reasoning whatsoever
what nature here he means something like
an instinct within us but it's it's not
actually gonna turn out to be purely
instinctual there's some input coming in
and we we process it and we come up with
this principle so he says that though we
should conclude that in all reasonings
from experience there is a step taken by
the mind which is not supported by any
argument or process of the understanding
meaning we're always kind of taking a
leap of faith to some degree in you know
the things that we're reasoning about in
the world or even within ourselves we
uses the passions as examples well we
might think about the passions of other
people as well so he says there is such
a step which is not supported there is
no danger that these reasonings on which
almost all knowledge depends will ever
be affected by such a discovery so two
other key things all right almost all of
our knowledge depends on this on taking
these leaps but there's no danger
well why what is the principle that
allows us to do that a says let's
consider two people before we have the
big reveal all right so one person is
very bright he says they're endowed with
the strongest faculties of reason and
reflection they have no cognitive
difficulties at all they can reason
things out sort of like a computer
that's got a you know amazing processor
but it doesn't even have any input so he
says imagine a person like this to be
brought on a sudden into the world what
would they observe what would they
experience he says it would just be a
continual succession of objects and one
event following another
okay so that's like what we experienced
but there's a vital difference he says
he would not be able to discover
anything further he would not at first
by any reasoning be able to reach the
idea of cause and effect why not
the particular powers by which all
natural operations are performed never
appear to the senses so he can't get it
through the senses nor is it reasonable
to conclude merely because one event in
one instance precedes another that
therefore one is the cause the other the
effect the conjunction may be arbitrary
and casual so this person is thrust
forth into the world that we know and
experience and they're not able to make
sense of it they're not able to see it
in the way that we almost automatically
do why because they they're lacking
something now consider the case of
another person he says suppose again
that this person has acquired more
experience he's lived so long in the
world to have to have observed similar
objects or events to be constantly
conjoined together what is the
consequence of this experience
he immediately infers the existence of
one object from the appearance of the
other yet he is not by all his
experience acquired any idea or
knowledge of the secret power by which
one object produces the other nor is it
by any process of reasoning he's engaged
to draw this inference but he does find
himself determined to draw it even
though he's convinced his understanding
as no part in the operation he would
nevertheless continue in the same course
of thinking this is kind of puzzling
isn't it right he got a person who
didn't have any experience now he's got
some and without like having to reason
it out and say to himself oh you know
I've noticed that in many cases this
thing here happens and then this thing
happens I should you know reason that
there's a high probability that this
will produce this there's nothing like
that going on if there is a reasoning
process it's largely implicit or
unconscious so what's actually happening
here
Hume says we've got a principle that's
going on and this principle determines
him to form this conclusion what is this
principle
he says it's custom or habit he prefers
the word custom I think in the present
we would prefer the term habit because
we're inclined to think of habits of
thought and habits of behavior and if
we're you know sort of inclined towards
a virtue ethics or even just you know
trying to make ourselves more productive
with life hacks or something like that
we do understand the force of habit for
changing not just what we do but also
our mindsets
what is habit or or custom for Hume he
tells us that it's a propensity what is
the propensity propensity by the way is
a tendency a disposition to doing
something to to having something go a
certain way the book has a propensity to
fall if I drop it I have a propensity if
you've watched many of my videos to
where it's hi and a button-down shirt
when I'm shooting them doesn't doesn't
mean in every single case that I do that
of course although the book will and in
fact if there's nothing blocking it fall
pretty you know every time we think
right so this propensity says to renew
the same act or operation without being
impelled to by any reasoning or process
of the understanding so we're not
thinking it through it's not something
cognitive in the sense of discursive
where we lay it out or like okay so this
should happen this should happen this
should happen know the same actor
operation happens and he says we always
say that this propensity is the effect
of custom now custom in the time that
humans talking about this covers a lot
of ground it can be the individual and
what they're accustomed to it can also
talk about sort of the the the pressure
of social forces and viewpoints on
things that go without being questioned
it was viewed as important to not get
rid of customs unless you have good
reasons for that
you know I'll give you a prime example
of something that would be a custom when
a whole bunch of people are going to be
do
and they have to be processed
individually what do they typically do
do they mob around and just kind of jump
in there every once in a while sometimes
but usually we form an orderly line
right that's a custom that doesn't have
to be the case and there's probably
different ways of doing it calling it
forming a line is one way of talking
about it that's you know my custom
forming a queue would be how British
people would would say it and standing
on line is the way people describe it on
the East Coast whereas if you say
standing on line here people are gonna
look at in the Midwest people will look
at you like you're nuts
those are all manners of custom so he
goes out and he says in employing this
word we don't pretend to have given the
ultimate reason of such a propensity
we're just pointing out a principle of
human nature universally acknowledged
well-known by its effects everyone's
going to grant that this takes place do
we know why it takes place no and he
says it's sufficient we can rest
contented with it was the ultimate
principle which we can assign all our
conclusions from experience but it's not
really an ultimate principle we don't
we're not at the very bottom of it we
don't know exactly how it works and that
might be something that psychologists
get into and indeed you know following
from David Hume psychologists devote a
lot of attention to that question but
he's not worried about it he's
interested in what we can say about it
from our ordinary experience so how does
it work he tells us that a constant
conjunction of two objects leads us to
expect them in a certain order so we you
know we see fire constantly conjoined
with smoke we assume when we see smoke
that there which is the effect that
there must be the cause governing it
when we see fire we think well there's
probably going to be some smoke coming
from that as a matter of fact we don't
say probably would say there will be and
that if we're you know called on it we
might say well in certain circumstances
maybe there won't be but probably right
or solidity and
how does he put it a solidity and weight
all right things that are solid objects
we expect them to weigh something if
they don't weigh anything we're really
surprised why because we've associated
those two things together in that case
what is the cause of what I think we
would say that the solidity is the cause
of the weight right although from a
physical perspective maybe we would say
the mass is the cause of the the
solidity mass and weight not being
exactly the same thing of course but you
see how this works and he brings up
examples of passions as well a little
bit later on he tells us about hatred
for example yeah here we go it's
unavoidable to feel the passion of love
when we receive benefits or hatred when
we meet with injuries right we sort of
come to see somebody injures somebody
else they feel the passion of hatred or
we ourselves are injured by somebody
else or something else and we feel
hatred towards it or I feel good stuff
coming we associate that with love and
so this is a matter of constant
conjunction how constant does the
conjunction have to be doesn't have to
be completely perfect as a matter of
fact the next section after this is
called on probability but we do want
there to be a you know fairly regular
connection right so he tells us that
custom ends up being as he calls it the
great guide to human life isn't that an
interesting idea there he tells us that
we expect the future to act like the
past he says it's that principle alone
which renders our experience useful to
us and makes us expect for the future a
similar train of effects with those that
have appeared in the past and so we can
see in this this discussion that it's
not just about classes of objects or
passions or whatever else they are that
are connected with each other there is
an overarching we might say a capital C
principle of custom
that tells us that when we observe
similar effects or connections in the
past we can expect to see similar things
in the future so you could call it like
a meta custom if you want to and we rely
on this to make our world coherent this
is what he says allows us to go beyond
the resources that are provided to us by
either memory of past experiences or
what we're directly experiencing now
through the senses otherwise we would be
stuck with what is immediately present
to those he says we would never know how
to adjust means to ends or employ our
natural powers and the production of any
effect there would be an end all at once
to all action as well as of the chief
part of speculation so in order to be
able to function within a world any sort
of environment to be able to use
ourselves to do things we need this this
principle of customer habit which then
takes memory senses also what it gets
from reason perhaps what it also gets
from culture you know it doesn't mean
that it's infallible and associating
these things and it connects them
together and gives us an output of
expect this you know expect this thing
to happen so he goes on and he tells us
something else that that that's quite
important he says that we we do this we
go beyond experience to infer all sorts
of things from distant places and most
remote ages again providing us with a a
world and so we do these associations
and he closes this section by saying
what then is the conclusion of the whole
matter a simple one though it must be
confessed pretty remote from the common
theories of philosophy so he's saying
this is something quite different than
what other philosophers are putting out
there my view on causality is that it
really boils down to the the way this
this custom works and he says matters or
belief of matter
a fact that is of empirical things in
the world or real existence whether
something is or isn't derives from
several different things working
together we need to have some sort of
object present to memory or the senses
and then we combine that with this
principle of custom he says customary
conjunction when we actually have that
then we can get these connections flame
and heap snow and cold
if flame or snow be presented and new to
the senses the mind is carried by custom
to expect heat or cold and to believe
that such a quality does exist and will
discover itself on a near approach and
he says this belief is the necessary
result of placing the mind in such
circumstances so without experience to
draw upon no customer habit it's it's
sort of like a latent property within us
and presumably within other animals as
well drawing conclusions like that
perhaps even it could be something if
we're thinking about machine learning
which is a rather metaphorical concept
there's something kind of like that
going on in that as well although that's
going far beyond what what Hume talks
about so this winds up being an
incredibly important principle needed
for anything that has to do with our
connection with ourselves and the world
you